investment banking
labor crunch a junior bankroll shortage
is forcing rainmakers to do grunt work
and firms are lowering the bar
for new hires business insider america
is facing labor shortages
spanning multiple industries banking
isn't immune just months after junior
bankers rallied
against management amid crushing levels
of burnout one of the root
drivers of the problem has yet to be
solved banks have too few hands on deck
to handle their massive deal loads
as a result some senior bankers have
been forced to roll up their sleeves
to work on deal processes that typically
would have been relegated
to the most entry-level employees
according to some banking insiders in
some cases the situation has gone to
dire the banks have been
have had to turn away business some
firms have easily
shed junior throughout the band which
have which have heavily shed juniors
throughout the
pandemic have recently been laterally
hiring juniors with minimal experience
who have a pretty steep learning curve
so can you imagine saying oh my gosh we
have so many deals we have to
we have to turn them down yeah what a
place to be
what a place to be what do you think
about that story pay people more money
and they will work
my god am i supposed to feel bad for
investment banking firms now that they
can't get cheap labor
for you come on enough already with
these guys my god i i am so dude i'm so
sick of wall street and the crony
capitalism man
look i i lost a lot of money on uh on my
stunks
when robin hood decided that they
weren't gonna let the hedge fund lose
all right i'm one of those guys that i
got crushed in that in that short
squeeze we were about to make a ton of
money
and they got together with old janet
yellen they said no no no we're not
we're not going to let we're not going
to let that that
that hedge fund go under we're just
going to shut down you can sell your
stuff
but you can't buy it but you can buy i
can't buy it yeah screw that and screw
these people
all right you want people to work pay
them
you want people to do the job so really
really well paid people at these firms
are crying because they don't want to do
this work because it's hard then pay
people more money to do the hard work
enough already i'm so sick how much of
it has to do with the fact that they're
getting paid to do nothing
which ones what the what the seniors
yeah they like
the junior bankers how much of it has to
do with that well you talking about the
stimulus that they got talking about the
fact that
the fact that stimulus check was
literally almost damn near six figures
dude
how much do i have to do yeah there's
this idea that people are supposed to
quote unquote do the right thing like
don't take the unemployment and go back
to work
screw that man if the government's
giving that money to all their buddies
you take that money too i have
absolutely zero
zero problem with somebody staying home
and caking off the government dime if
they're going to give this money to
raytheon they're going to give this
money to their own donors anyway
get yours man because otherwise i said
it last time if you're doing the right
thing
when everybody else isn't doing the
right thing you're not noble you're a
sucker
get cake sit home and cake man if they
want these people to work pat
if they want these people to work sell
some of those da vinci's that they got
hanging on in
the in the 118th floor of their mahogany
offices
and pay these dudes some money pete pay
people to work and they will come back
to work let me give you i
i uh kai who do i sit there sit with
this week who told me the story about
the guy that replaced the wework ceo
uh adam uh uh uh adam newman but the
the new guy can you pull up the new ceo
of uh the new ceo of uh wework who's the
new ceo i got the best story i got we
work ceo
i just i just don't have it in me i
can't cry let me tell you this story
uh uh so i'm speaking to a guy i don't
know who would i interview this week
who was the person i interviewed this
week uh business person i interviewed
anyway so i'm interviewing this guy and
he brings up the story of sandeep
and sandeep takes over we work
okay and he uh uh this this one guy is
shadowing him i wish i could remember
who i'm talking to this one guy's
shadowing him around him
oh peter tunney i'm with peter tony
who's an artist out of a wynwood
great artist love the work he's coming
to my house right after this
i gotta i've got something i
commissioned he's coming out to do
something he's done stuff for michelle
obama for jared kushner for trump for
everybody for bezos everybody's got his
piece
he's got a ridiculous he used to be
investment back in the days very
interesting guy says
at 14 years old i went to a party and we
were there was pot there was cocaine
there was everything there
he said i left the party at 45 years old
that's what he said
the guy's filled with stories so we go
to his place and this weekend i go and i
take shonda and i take
mario and i think sam we go there anyway
he tells a story about
his friend from wework sandeep took over
and he's got a good relationship with
him
he says pat let me tell you how this guy
did it he did it right
he says sandeep comes to want to save
wework
and they asked he i asked him a question
how did you save it he said very simple
this is what i did he says i live in a
two-bedroom place
okay he says i drive a volvo volvo he
says one of my top
guys that's making all the money he's
doing all this stuff they don't want to
go to work anymore they're just kicking
back again the problem senior brokers
they don't want to get to work they've
already earned it like i don't
i'm too good this happens in our
business as well ricky where people make
it
and they feel they're too entitled to go
run an appointment and meet with
somebody right six-figure golfers
there's no way i'm gonna come sit down
with you who do you think you are like
you realize how much money i make
they kind of start believing their own
hype he says here's what i did
how did you save wework he says i came
in and i knew what my
solution was going to be he said it was
making
2 000 calls a week for one straight year
then i was going to turn the company
around
and he says what was the caller like he
just sat there says he sits there right
in front of his desk
he's got to call him makes a phone call
hey john this is he says i have to make
two thousand six minute calls per month
and i can turn it around within a year
two thousand six minute calls
per in a month and i'll turn the company
on within a year he calls all the
property people that don't want to pay
the rent anymore
he's calling all the people we work he's
calling all the clients
hey so this is sandeep look uh you know
we gotta just want to call see how are
things what's going on
great fantastic look we got to get that
payment i understand you don't want to
pay i understand you're going through
struggles but let me tell you something
you got your ppp
you got the the house you're looking at
nobody told you to buy seven uh
you know bugattis nobody told you to go
buy that 40 million home nobody told you
do all that other stuff you did it
i need that payment to be made and i
need that payment to be made now okay
great
he says that's what i do all day to save
a company
a guy like that in the investment
banking world ends up
gaining so much respect from the street
because he does the work because he does
the work yeah there's a reason why he's
running
wework and replacing adam newman and
some guy who's
out there an investment banker who's
making a senior broker he's making a
million million and a half he thinks
he's already made it
and he doesn't want to go here's another
guy that comes in he's worth a half a
bill this guy's gonna end up being a
half a billion dollar type of guy the c
over uh wework right
they're not making a phone calls going
back to the drawing board it says look
running a company is sales you got to
make the phone calls unfortunately in
the world of business many people don't
make the phone calls
i tell you ron paul's story and then
we'll go to the next story
i'm sitting with ron paul four years ago
we're in houston
and we were you with us so we're sitting
with ron paul and it was four years ago
and i'm interviewing the guy
and uh what a genius of his brain is a
very interesting brain right
and he says uh you know years ago i'm a
doctor i think it was a was he was he
there were four thousand babies this was
right after the uh there was that
shooting his son got shot at during
the congressional yeah it was pretty
ugly but but he used to be a doctor and
i think he delivered four thousand
babies i don't know i think it's a four
thousand baby the number that he talks
about
he says one day i hear about this
economist he says so i go while i'm a
doctor
i go to hear him speak and i go once and
i go twice i go three times i go four
times
he says i keep going back to the guy and
he tells the guy
i don't know who it was he says i tell
the guy that look
i can't get the stuff out of my head and
i want to tell the world about it
what do i do ron paul gave the most
ridiculous story
watch what he says he says the guy told
me ron don't worry about it
he says when you believe in a real cause
and when you believe in a real cause and
it's not
fake and you can't help but talk about
it
it's a crusade you can't help but talk
about it don't worry
the right people will eventually find
you and give you a platform wow
what a statement right and look at the
guy what he did he raised six million
dollars on myspace
in 24 hours and that became the at 69
years old and everybody realized
raising money is on social media nobody
exactly
they stole the whole love and everything
like that i love revolution he also said
something else in that that was really
brilliant
um that he you asked him what the
problem was this might have been off air
while we were setting up the cameras
he asked them you know what what's the
problem with washington like why why
can't people get together
and he said everybody's a lawyer they're
trained to win
oh yeah that no he said that that's it
he said that they
they don't care if they're right or
wrong they're they're literally trained
winners they're trained to win no matter
what it's that's you go to law school
to learn how to win right that's
literally it that's in the game so yeah
so he's a doctor
yeah and then he was describing to you
that there's maybe like four other
businessmen and there's one guy from mit
and then
everybody else is a lawyer so you have
two people then they're they they could
tell you
you know over dinner like hey look
you're totally right about this we
this is something that we shouldn't do
and then the next day on the floor and
be like we have to do this this is for
america
it doesn't matter they just they're
there to win
and he thinks because they're lawyers
there's not enough of a of a cross
section right
there's no t they don't know there's no
teachers in in congress there's no
farmers in congress there's no
entrepreneurs barely entrepreneur
you know if you even if you want to
count you know mitt romney
i mean he he cuts people up and chops
them in half you know what i mean he's
he's not
he doesn't build businesses he actually
made his entire career on tearing him
down and pardon him out he's a
he runs a chop shop you know what i'm
saying so not that you would know
anything about it
but yeah so i mean that that's that's
part of this interesting thing as well
you know we keep
every time i listen to the podcast and
your valuetainers you know they they
their comments are great and they're
always something to the effect of
everybody wants consensus yeah pat's
always talking about the left and the
right have to come together the people
online
respond to that and it's not that we're
like in some site
some sort of isolated echo chamber where
it's like hey
working together helps like every human
on earth knows that working together is
better than
than you know going head to head with
each other but there has to be some sort
of examination
of the functions at place that
preclude us from being able to do this
like why can't we get together and this
is one of the things ron paul said that
i thought was really really salient
they're they're lawyers so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye